la commune effectivement est une toute
petite commune rurale qui compte pas de
grands bâtiments historiques ou de
monuments particulier le seul élément
patrimonial qu'on puisse savoir que
c'était c'était l'école communale et
puis c'est un lieu qui est très
fédérateur aux au sein de la population
où beaucoup de gens ont usé leurs fonds
de culotte sur ces vieilles tables en
sapin et c'est un lieu où les gens
aiment bien se retrouver voilà qui parle
beaucoup aussi bien aux anciennes
générations coup aux jeunes enfants qui
parce que la commune allait bien c'est
en général une époque de la vie qu'on
tonga ne plus tôt à mon souvenir
batoul eu le gros mobilier les tables
sont d'époque les le mobilier d'époque
là une grande partie des objets sont de
froideville et puis il ya il ya dans les
petits objets il y en a énormément je
fais régulièrement les puces cette année
nous allons être ouvert à l'occasion des
journées du patrimoine des 15 et 16
septembre
c'est la première fois que nous
participerons à cette manifestation puis
ça nous semble intéressant pour ouvrir
plus largement ce lieu à un public qui
n'a jamais eu l'occasion de
lire ici